a suburban home here look cunning
predators who will not rest until they
have driven sleep into extinction they
have evolved to admit a blue light that
is remarkably similar to daylight humans
attracted by the light soon find
themselves mesmerised but the lights
suppresses the production of melatonin a
hormone that contributes to their
circadian rhythm they are exhausted but
blissfully unaware of their exhaustion a
side effect of sleep deprivation in this
condition they are more accident-prone
[Music]
have impaired judgment and are more
irritable sensing danger
the matriarch gathers her mate and they
scurry off to their den here
they have artfully shaped their habitat
to block out anything that could put
their sleep in jeopardy
soothing colors warm lighting and soft
bedding create an ideal habitat for
sleep but the predator has entered their
den if it can ensnare the pray he will
rob them of their precious sleep in a
brilliant maneuver the female stands her
ground corners the predator and fend off
the attack with a final touch sleep has
been saved from extinction
[Music]